[Music]
all right guys let me show you a picture
and you're gonna
tell me what you think this this is
inkblot tests
no oh birth control thing what do you
think this is birth control
it's like that uh michelangelo jesus
picture big cop ring that's a small
cockroach small sized cockpit yeah well
yikes i don't know tiny ones i give up
for babies
tests covet tests okay consenting
bracelets i still think
birth control because it looks like it's
two different buttons okay
i like the way your brains are thinking
except you steve i don't like it you
don't like that you like
it's a [ __ ] ring i put together the the
significance of the yellow and the blue
and why they're shaped like that and why
there's two buttons
that's always thinking the consenting
bracelet i think could be a good option
you're getting warm with closure is that
that's interesting
or like you want to be my friend and we
push the buttons at the same time hey
you want to [ __ ] like i
said actually i take it back you're not
warm i'll take it back that's not it's
not a consenting bracelet no it's not
how about it just trying to like see if
like it's more there then
is it sexy it's not sex involved i think
it's a tracking device
is it friendship friendship friendship
definitely something that involves two
people i feel like
it's like you're going out of the house
let me track you okay
what do you think red i was gonna say
like a period tracker like hurry trucker
when you're gonna go on your period
that's gross red
[Applause]
is it a reminder type of thing no
it's not [ __ ] and it's not about
tracking your period
is it the new i watch no why would you
be handing it to someone like that
and it's a it's a guy hand to a girl
hand too oh well no don't get caught up
on that
what it's just heart attack it's a
wristband
oh it's for diabetes no no that would be
an apple thing to do though like we took
away the screen
we took away the plug-ins no more of
that [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] you guys man [ __ ] headphones
yeah what time is it
we took away the time there's no more
time
we're not gonna have a power jack by the
next one for sure exactly yeah
is it like only wireless charging yeah
that's why they have the mag safe in the
background
you're [ __ ] right is it for energy no
you guys remember those bands do you
guys remember that they were selling
those bands and then they're like
all right put the band on it and see if
i could [ __ ] get your i know what it
is
wait oh yeah final answer it's a it's a
mood ring it's a movie
oh we are the closest one okay so you're
feeling good that day feeling bad that
day
is your mood that's it you nailed it
that's what it is it's a horny bracelet
not horny so yellow means you're in a
good mood
blue means you're in a you need a
bracelet to [ __ ] teach you oh okay
like you fill in the blue yeah not not
so good so it's like a mood tracker
how does it know but more convenient you
press it yourself oh that's better
because i was gonna be mark cuban for a
second
this is [ __ ] oh like when you're
feeling like [ __ ] you're like
yeah so while you're arguing with your
[ __ ] partner you're like
yeah you look at my bracelet [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of cool cause it's like uh
like people like to do mood trackers
every day now to see how they are i do
sleep for the month
but this one could be multiple times a
day so you could really see how in
you're emotional if you're wondering if
you're really a sad ass [ __ ] well you
can really check with this
look at your weekly chart [ __ ] i feel
like it's due it's just detracted
there's no like
uh upside or like a solution to whatever
so
the the receiving end of this bracelet
is your boss so
i don't know if i like anymore yeah yeah
so this company is called moon beam
and they develop like this she ended up
developing
the woman behind this this bracelet
initially because
her daughter was having a hard time at
school and she kind of wanted to be
there for her daughter so she ended up
having this idea of creating a wristband
where like her daughter can just
notify her throughout the day how what
her mood is and how
she's feeling and work through it and so
she ended up that's some real helicopter
parenting [ __ ] dude
mike she can't let go of the umbilical
cord [ __ ] my ancestors knew that
humanity would end up like this they
would have aborted
all of us yeah it's pretty crazy
but so anyway they would have dove off
the cliffs of valhalla and [ __ ] dude
like they would have put their guns down
in normandy
yeah like what are we fighting for this
is what the future's gonna be like
let's just end it here guys yeah we're
cool nothing to fight for
but yeah so so anyway so then that was
the idea behind it but then now
it's targeted more towards employers to
monitor how their staff are coping
with working from home so it's like
all at once they can ask 500 members are
you okay without picking up the phone
so that's like what they're kind of like
selling it here with
and so it's just kind of helping
employers
check in with their employees and having
their employees it's another way where
people can avoid
confrontation and have be a [ __ ]
adult and say yo
look like we need to have a conversation
so it's attached
directly to the name of the employee
who's doing it or is it anonymous or is
that another i was reading up on it
and so initial tests were anonymous
but then they found out so it's more
statistical is what they're trying to
get after
yeah but they found out that people
using the wristbands
wanted to be identified so then the
employees yeah i'm sad
but would they be honest at that point
you know what i mean
or are they like oh we just had a
meeting with the boss i'm gonna put
happy
you know to like yeah we're in the
meeting with the boss so you're just
like
like you wouldn't actually like do that
would you to like be
that honest and like oh every time you
meet with your boss happy for sure
unless you're a [ __ ] ass kisser yeah
but then i mean at that point you're
really just creating your own problems
because you're not really getting your
problems met
i mean it seems like this is meant for
people who are already not direct enough
to tell them
right well it sounds like it's more of a
of a cheat for the employers not
necessarily for the employees
it's more like for the employers to be
like without having to check in they get
to check in
but if you have a willingness like if
you're
like like nelson's saying yeah but if
you're if you have like a
a financial need to stay at this company
and so you're you're like
willfully like i'm not gonna say my real
thoughts
yay it's great like i don't see why they
would be incentivized to say the other
other thing
because anonymous i feel like would make
sense in terms of uh
corporate structuring so every time they
did something and they noticed that
there's a bunch of negative
reviews coming up all the time what are
we doing wrong like oh maybe we
shouldn't do it this way
yeah but if it's just attached to that
one office
[ __ ] walks through and everyone's
like that's that's that's sad
they're like at 3 pm this always happens
and they're like oh it's cause of
[ __ ] eric man
and yeah and it's like man [ __ ] eric
that is his name huh we should have
known
no but yeah so they're saying that uh
there was this one report
i found that 60 of adults said that
their mental health has gotten
worse during the pandemic and 67.
i can completely see that and
many not wanting to speak up about their
problems because they feel that other
people
need more help than they do so anyone
that's
pent up in the house i think is gonna
just cause that
period like because we're all locked up
yeah exactly anyone who feels like they
can't
be themselves or be social or any of
that yeah
socializing is so important yep get to
talk to people relate to people event
but if you're just
all cooped up week after week after week
especially if you're like a young adult
they can't drink and dance anymore with
their friends
and when most of your interactions they
don't even know if you're smiling
yeah like it's yeah it's really weird
get that for human connection
the reciprocation of the feelings
through the facial muscles
yeah so what do they do what's the
solution
well uh employees well yeah so here it's
more like
it's more like they don't do anything oh
you're sad it's more like reporting
about
it and having the employer be like oh
you actually
are like this is a form of like speaking
out i guess reaching out yeah like
reaching out
and and trying to get some help so then
i guess the employer would then
step in and try to help in any sort of
situation
we need more bean bags they're just not
happy right now
it's all about the chairs man yeah i
wonder
wait outside of la a lot of places are
just open right
like they're still going in to work yeah
california's pretty locked down
texas is pretty open yeah florida's open
yeah yeah but it seems like for a lot of
like
the whole country if you don't have to
go into the office
they're not making people go in oh like
so work at home is pretty standard now
huh yeah it sounds like it sure seems
like in l.a bro
got here in 25 minutes i know
never used to happen pre-panda do you
think
after this we'll ever go back to the
same kind of work
like office i don't think so i was
talking
to my friends who like did work in an
office all the time
and they say because they said that
the way the company is going to
restructure a lot of them now or they're
going to have like
meetings once a week twice a week that
you do need to come in because some of
those are just important to be in person
but a lot of their actual work is being
moved home so now to me like a half at
home half
in person kind of deal when everything
comes back up again we just stole
our work style before damn man you know
what uh one of our friends
stole our workspace one of our friend's
girlfriend's company has everyone just
log on to zoom like it's a nine to five
though
oh and they're just on zoom the whole
thing is odd is that right yeah so
everyone is on zoom and that square is
on from nine to five
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah cause the cool thing
about being in an office
is that you can have access so like when
you're in an office
you can just go to your co-workers
cubicle you can work there and then just
i don't know but at least there's not a
[ __ ] camera right here in front of
you yeah like i'm gonna be watching
that's so awkward and weird
yeah yeah hello it's like oh yeah you're
here oh [ __ ]
i can't focus that's interesting because
like
for isaac's school for example most of
his schooling
he doesn't have to have his camera on
but he does say that sometimes the
teacher will request like
oh you're like turn your camera on for
this part or whatever and then they do
and so you have to see the kid but for
the most of it
he's never being watched so you could
play [ __ ] wars on it i took a class
uh pandemic he's getting straight a's
man
i took a class a a motorcycle writing
course
that we took prior to the pandemic where
we went into a classroom remember that
and then you have to do lecture and all
that there it's the same class
but now um they do it online so you take
the writing
proportion like yeah physically but then
all of the lecture was done online and
the way that
they do it is like for roll call or
whatever you have to show your face
and then you could turn it off if you
want but they'll ask you questions
periodically to make sure that you're
listening
my friends just took the writing course
like two weeks ago he says it's really
crazy right now because they cap how
many people that can do it yeah it's
booked all the way till the summer right
now
yeah it was it's crazy riding portion
they could only have like four people
compared to before what 15 16 people
were there yeah it was like full class
yeah that's crazy ours was like less
than 10.
yeah but i had to do it again because my
other thing had expired so oh
that's why you did it again yeah but
it's crazy how they're running these
things man i was like you could have
done this like why
you know why didn't you do it before
true because it would have been hella
efficient they could have like 300
people inside of the online class or
whatever
wait but let me tell you something that
really irked me recently so i got a new
doctor
and at this new doctor they're forcing
me forcing me
to go into the office to make my
appointment with my doctor which will be
a virtual appointment
that's weird are you kidding me exactly
is it is it for proof of pers like who
you are
so the thing is that um they did say it
was because of the paperwork because
it's a hipaa violation to send it
through email and i'm like that's cool
but tell me why my ob gyn
gave me all my new patient paperwork
years ago before the pandemic
through their website which was a hippa
approved apparently damn
and and yeah like all they asked for was
a picture of my [ __ ] on the iphone and
i [ __ ] sent that [ __ ]
and it was easy i even had to go into
the office dog paid me they paid me
they're like
are you sure that's obgyn and that's not
only fans
my ob gyn is this [ __ ] so i'm like are
you [ __ ] kidding me i had to walk
in person for this [ __ ] paperwork i
could just give you
over the [ __ ] and what did they say
they're like yeah
and then you're like all right we just
miss people they're like
wait send us a picture of your [ __ ]
though stupid no but i got so annoyed
because she was like yeah well you know
because of kovid
we're not gonna have in-person uh
[ __ ]
appointments and i'm like but i have to
come in for the
[ __ ] point so stupid i'm so annoyed
brutal
can't just go to another doctor or do
you think they all run it the same way
now
i probably could but it took me a long
time to find this one this one's dope
d-o yeah with the p-e dope because he's
a d.o not a md
oh i don't get it
[Music]
you